Good news for masochists
and old receipt enthusiasts
'cause Tax Day is Mon...
Oh, (bleep), Tax Day's Monday.
Ah... Poop, poop, poop.
That means millions of Americans
are currently screaming,
"Oh, (bleep),
Tax Day is Monday,"
as they realize
it's way past midnight
and they don't even know
what a 1040EZ is.
It's tough navigating all the
loopholes and the deductions,
which is why we've enlisted the
help of three financial experts,
a comedian, a sportscaster,
and a half-shaved Wolverine.
Uh, so, comedians...
-Sorry, Annie.
-It's not... -Nice.
Again. Again.
Comedians, I want you to give us
as many...
"Yeah, these wolverines just
left you on our doorstep, Mike.
"We don't know...
You're not naturally our child.
"You were raised in the wild.
Now it's time you knew."
You don't have a stomach like
this and a healing factor, okay?
Comedians, I want you to give us
as many last minute tax tips
as you can in 60 seconds.
And begin. Annie.
When listing your dependents,
find out how many people have
your Netflix password.
All right. Points. Rich Eisen.
-Lie.
-Yeah, points. Mike.
Make sure your accountant's name
rhymes with "Ibowitz."
Points. Annie.
Write off Axe Body Spray
as a business expense,
because your business
is getting that pussy...!
All right, points. Points.
Yeah!
Rich.
Take no advice
from Wesley Snipes.
All right, points.
Mike Lawrence.
You only have to claim
the children you wanted.
Points. Points. Annie.
Buying Mike Lawrence's CD
counts as a charity.
-All right.
-(groaning, laughter)
-Shots fired.
-Points.
Very nicely done, Annie. Rich.
Get real rich
and just don't pay them.
Yes, points. Annie.
Say your cat is your wife
and your dog is a religion.
(buzzer sounds)